hello I'm a nostalgic ring guy remember
it so you don't have to this is a story
about a boy and his Willie let me try it
again this is a story about a boy his
relationship with his little whale no
this is a story about a boy who likes to
hold on to his big fish okay this isn't
what you think it has Michael Jackson in
it okay just yeah you remember this
little classic don't you to
misunderstood soul share a special bond
and neither one can explain but neither
one would give up for the world never
heard that before except for a boy in
his raccoon and a boy and his dog the
boy and his hog and the point is
multiple alien knock-offs so the story
was really nothing new at the time it is
still turn out to be a big hit why well
let's look at this whale of a fail to
find out so it starts off with the
action of whales jumping actually I
should say a TV sleep stretches out the
action of whales jumping for two and a
half minutes but then we come across our
enemy now they capture one of the whales
in their nets and take them away as our
opening creditors show
Wow what first year photo chefs didn't
put that title together so we come
across our boy-girl thing as we see him
and his friends make a living by common
people out of money and stealing their
daily food so the points named Jesse and
he lives in that special time in movies
where Runaways are cool can survive on
their own and somehow has relatively
clean hair despite the fact that they
have nowhere to stay while running away
from the cops they hide in the back room
of an aquarium where they spray paint
the walls because that's what tough
blonde curly haired white boys do
what is that yeah I saw this in a book
somewhere
I think it's called marketable so almost
instantly a connection is made between
the boy and the whale the chassis is
caught by the cars and brought down to
the station ah you missed me do wives
don't play don't come in here being a
bony we were lucky this time I kept you
little behind out of court oh hey that's
imported black person looking out for a
lost white person yeah I haven't seen
that in a movie since every movie ever
made I think yes my mom you still want
me to hear from your mom I just want to
know if she's okay nobody's heard from
your mom and six years Jessie your
father on the other hand wrote to
another letter from prison he says tell
you you're older so the kid is given a
foster home with a perfectly nice couple
which of course he ate in fact that's
how I know Dwight I did a story on
Cooper ton widget jerk so what exactly
are you into Jesse I'm not into talking
or eating well you won't know what I'm
into child abuse
lots of it you wanna see a sample of
that you little shit your room Jesse
you've got the best view in the house
it's great to have you here Jesse
alright so as you can tell this little
boy is about as cliched as a movie
runaway key the only thing missing is
employee on harmonica well don't you
so it turns out as part of his probation
he has to go clean the graffiti that he
left on the whales tank here he
befriends a Gandhi mr. Johnson who can't
seem to train really no matter how hard
him and his staff try when he gets in
the mood you gotta give him his space
you know what I mean
don't bother him he won't bother you you
understand sure I hope you make no
connection to that animal whatsoever I
don't want to see any of that kindred
spirits stuff he also sees one of the
other trainers played by Maury penny
you're like a Petey kid aren't you I
guess you really messed up our
observation area yeah well you messed up
tank girl we also see the parts owner
who's played by the villain from the
next Karate Kid well wouldn't you know
it he's playing the villain here I think
it's because his eyebrows are
permanently cemented to do slope it will
cost at least a hundred thousand expend
a psychotic noggin hence play
I've gotta ain't that well you know I
love Gilmore Girls weird off so as you
would guess the boy playing is Emraan
account willy start to make a connection
they're both unsatisfied animals with
everything they need and you talk to Lee
want to escape what's not to connect
with he even sneaks into the park to
play this harmonica at night because
didn't you do that when you were a kid
so after a thorough search it turns out
that Jesse almost drowns
but of course Willy the whale who
couldn't love say it's the boy's life I
assume it's because he likes his food
dry but maybe he wants him as well
you saved my life but still why did he
save the boy's life they were looking to
win his eyes those eyes discovered the
Stars long before a man was even a
whisper on mother earth look into a
man's soul earthly life you won't look
at ray or me maybe he sees you
or maybe that's bullshit I uh we could
use him for the rest of the summer
that's alright with you make a job of it
Peyman little something to if the least
I can offer after he broke into my theme
park vandalized my walls and disturb my
wheel so Jessie is now working there as
a professional boy as he notices
Willie's disturbances deeper than he
thought God it sounds like curly having
a hernia so it turns out the owners of
the park I'm treating it very well but
that's because they don't have the
misunderstood heart of gold that Jessie
has like rubbery still good friend
yeah real streetwise kid like I said hey
I ain't playing man this is the real
deal hey you don't like it shut out your
piehole you're such a beautiful animal
so the kid starts training the whale
without even knowing it as mr. Johnson
and the other trainer think that maybe
he should be the one to train him for a
show so she trains the kid to train the
whale as their bond gets even closer and
closer but something still seems to be
missing from Willy's life
yes sounds like snot from Thundercats
getting neutered but it turns out
something is missing from Jessie's life
too as he discusses it with his foster
father that's a picture of me my mother
she died about two years ago yeah well
my mom's coming to get me one of these
days you don't believe me do you
I don't care what those people said
those people don't know anything so
their little argument gets his foster
parents in another little argument which
finally reminds Jesse to open up his
welcome home gift right like we don't
owe anybody anything so after seeing the
trouble he's caused he realizes that
maybe he can be kind maybe he can
understand maybe he can be a little
douche and throw a baseball through a
window Oh should have gotten a puppy are
you okay aren't you guys fighting it
scared me yeah I can totally relate
oh let's spider so the bad guy drops by
to see the trainer's progress thank you
thank you good boy Jesus I swear this
guy is a robot
disengage in press mode engage smoke
indifference so you can do all that
again would you and Ray want cost a lot
of money I have to be sure dogs pee on
brick walls let me check my douchebag
files for that the Willy show it'll make
money and that my friend is what we are
all about yes in case you didn't get the
subtlety that he was the villain before
he just flat-out says all we care about
is the mud why don't you spell the
ending of Titanic with a sad face and a
broken heart while you're at it so
everything is set for the Willy show
Willy get spooked because people
downstairs are ooh gasp tapping on the
glass so let me get this straight these
killer whales that eat seals dolphins
and even other whales can't take simple
tapping on glass the I guess all seals
need to scare them away our miniature
windshields in the spoon that'll keep
them away for good geez Willy please God
don't like jar jar binks in a blender so
will it get so mad at the constant
clamping that he actually Rams the glass
which actually results in one of my
favorite scenes from one of the henchmen
no one can eat popcorn so devilishly
seriously you can put that like any
heartwarming scene it would just suck
the love right out of it
I'll never doubt again I won't have a
bad name
you see it makes anything sinister
trigger on some other moods
what's he waking up with so Jesse gets
bombed out that Willy bailed out so the
supportive black guy comes in to try and
talk some sense into him sit in this
place
go and find my mom the state can't find
your mom the federal government can't
find your mom even when are you gonna
get your mom isn't coming back
turned around and drove away didn't look
around didn't slow down didn't even look
in the rearview mirror if this is the
motivational speech I suggest a rewrite
so Jesse packs up his things and decides
to run away again where is he going in
my best good California California shut
up
Oh some point William Hung sucking on
helium sure so what is it Willie's been
crying about all this time it's your
family Wow
none of those marine biologists just
noticed a bunch of killer whales happen
to be waiting outside the park will
observe it but it turns out
revolutionist henchmen try to destroy
the tank so they can collect the
insurance money that Willy is worth your
would more dead than alive so what our
heroes going to do let's pray really I
never liked this job anyway yeah it's
not like calling the police or animal
control will play any part here nope
it's up to a Native American a small boy
and tanker that makes logical sense how
we're going to pull oh no wait I'll tell
you what makes even more sense stealing
your foster parents truck when you find
out later that they willingly would have
helped you in the first place yes your
brains yeah well okay it's a whale of a
chase as we see our villain dressed as
you have no gear chases our heroes to
the water
ah fuck adoption fuck fuck fuck adoption
but the bad guys have sealed off their
only way out laying their net so that
Willie can get caught forget me okay so
it looks like this is goodbye that
famous scene that's shown on all the
posters I'm a trailer and even on the
front the DVD yeah it looks like that's
not going to happen that whales not
going anywhere
what is 20 feet deep those Nets a touch
bottom glow city not only this calls for
a victory snort care to join me oh boy
okay so we all know this scene and we
all know the jokes made about the way
only maze it halfway the whale crunches
the boy the whale eats the boy while
jumping over we've seen all the same
tyres but here's my question that
nobody's ever brought up if we can jump
over several feet of solid rock why
couldn't he just jump over the Nats
they're underwater all he has to do is
jump half a centimeter and he's free
there was no point in jumping over those
fucking rocks it's totally dumb
gotta hate that well though well at
least I still got my white shark
insurance at SeaWorld so the kid
reunites with his foster parents and
Willy reunites with his family
there it is Free Willy what's my take
well I can't say it's a terrible movie
but it's not really that good
there's very few surprises in it because
we seen this story a hundred times we
just haven't seen it with a wailing yet
but aside from that it hits every note
that we've seen in every other movie
about a kid and his pet there's really
nothing different to it so why was this
movie such a big hit because Michael
Jackson did the song for it that's right
that's the only reason I think this
movie made money he was still like one
of the biggest things in the world at
the time so if he said he watched this
way people are gonna watch that fucking
whale look like I said it's not a
terrible movie I mean it's not as bad as
something like a troll in central but
yeah no I know this works yeah if I say
the entire title that means that I had
to review it next week yeah I know this
joke yeah I'm not doing it mm-hmm
there's no way that you're gonna get me
to say a troll in Central Park